a spacecraft is just hours away from
Impact with a far-off asteroid a
multinational Mission which could be
instrumental in some day preserving
human civilization NASA's double
asteroid redirection test or Dart is a
570 kilogram spacecraft launched in
November 2021 traveling at more than six
kilometers per second it is on track to
smash itself to pieces on the surface of
a small asteroid called dimorphos 11
million kilometers from Earth the object
is to alter dimorphoses trajectory
slightly
small nudge is about deflection not
disruption it's not the Hollywood
Blockbuster of blowing it into a bunch
of pieces small nudge find it many years
in advance and that adds up to a big
change in position with times
the asteroids path will be studied by
Earth observatories and satellites for
years to come
dimorphous itself is not on a course to
collide with Earth but massive objects
have struck numerous times in our
planet's history one of the biggest in
recent times was the tunguska event a
meteor that exploded over a remote and
uninhabited area of Siberia in 1908
flattening 80 million trees over an area
of 2000 kilometers
still 65 million years ago a huge object
crashed near the Yucatan Peninsula
causing Global Devastation scientists
believe that impact is directly linked
to the extinction of the dinosaurs to
prevent Humanity from going the way of
the T-Rex scientists and Engineers hope
to develop a system to nudge threatening
asteroids away from Earth once they are
identified once you find the asteroid
and you have its orbit you really can be
in this position where you have the
warning time where you really would be
able to do things decades in advance and
that's completely realistic the impact
will be captured by the spacecraft's
on-board camera promising a dramatic
view of an experiment which may one day
be remembered as helping prevent
Armageddon Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera